معدلات النجاه من مرض السرطان وصلت الى
قفزه كبيره في الخمسين عاما الماضيه وتوقع
الباحثون في مركز الدولي لابحاث السرطان
بجراه ان بعض انواع السرطان تنقرض في
السنوات القادمه من نظر الى جميع انواع
السرطان يتوقع ان ترتفع معادلات الشفاء
الى 60 بالمئه في العقد المقبل قبل ان
ترتفع الى 80% في عام 2045 احد الجوانب
الرئيسيه لتحسين معادلات النجوم من
السرطان بحسب الخبراء هو التشخيص السريع
فاذا كنت تريد الحفاظ على معدل شفاء مرتفع
فمن المهم حقا تجلى السرطان في اقرب وقت
ممكن بالنسبه لبعض انواع السرطان من
المتوقع بالفعل ان ينجو اكثر من تسعه من
عشره من كل عشره اشخاص من المرهم وهذا
يشمل سرطان الجلد عند النساء وسرطان
الخصيه اما سرطان الثدي والغده الدرقيه
تزيد نسبه البقاء على قيد الحياه عن 70%
ويمكن ان يؤدي لاكتشاف المبكر الى تحسين
هذه النسبه
السرطان عنق الرحم يمكن ان ينقر التقريبا
بفضل نجاح برنامج لقاح فيروز الورى من
حليم البشري الا ان معدلات البقاء على قيد
الحياه على المدى الطويل لبعض اشكال المرض
مثل سرطان الرئه والبنكرياس لا تزال اقل
من 10%